as a lot of you guys know we're
expecting a very
exciting apple event next week on
tuesday the 23rd
and according to some leaks and rumors
apple might
actually release the new airpods 3 which
many people were waiting for
for a long time however there is also
some very bad news that i want to
discuss
as well but before i get into my
thoughts on when they'll actually be
getting released
i want to first go through a quick
history of the leaks and rumors
surrounding the airpods 3. over a year
ago
it was reported that apple was working
on airpods pro
lite which basically looked like the
pros but lacked the noise cancellation
features
and that could actually be the airpods 3
and then in april digitimes basically
reported the same thing
the new airpods 3 simply having a
similar design
to the pros and once again in june
exactly the same thing but this time
coming from the reliable analyst
minshakuo and he also believes that
they're going to launch in the first
half of 2021 as well as digitimes
with some unnamed sources in the
vietnamese supply chain
where they will apparently be
manufactured but a few months later
quo claimed that the airpods 3 will have
a hybrid design
somewhere between the airpods 2 and the
airpods pro
but he said that they're likely getting
delayed until april
may or june and then after that point we
got our very first look at a leaked pair
of airpods 3
from 52audio.com where they look kind of
like the earpods pros
but without the silicon tip and just by
looking at these renders
it seems like this could actually be
something that apple would put out
and by the way if you don't know who 52
audio is
that's the website which successfully
leaked the design of the airpods pro
before they were released so they
definitely have a really good track
record
according to the elec the airpods 3 may
cost 199 dollars
and come with an h1 chip inside once
again coming in the first half of 2021
so those right there were some of the
older leaks and rumors that we discussed
already
in our last air pods leak video but
since then
a massive amount of things have changed
so let's get right into it
of course the march event has all but
been confirmed to be happening on the
23rd
so because of that many people are
expecting the airpods 3
to be released at the event however last
month
john prosser said that he's only heard
about ipads and
air tags being released at the march
event so it's possible that airpods
will be released later but then on the
other hand
52 audio started releasing more images
of the new airpods 3
and john prosser ended up saying that
these new leaks are
legitimate and just after that he
tweeted again
now finally adding airpods into the
products that he expects to come at the
event
on the 23rd and just within the last few
days
we started to get some very interesting
leaks and rumors
gizmo china released some brand new
renders of the airpods 3
and they look basically identical to the
ones that 52 audio
previously showed and sam from
appletrack.org
said that the airpods 3 releasing at the
march event is
a safe bet due to all of these leaks
popping up recently
we then got even more images of the
airpods 3 from 52 audio
which are beginning to become much more
convincing
and i now personally believe that these
right here
are 100 legit leaks and they're
exactly what we should expect and this
time around 52 audio added that the
price tag
will most likely be around a hundred and
fifty dollars
which would be awesome since the first
price tag rumor
pointed to a 200 price which was a bit
pricey
for non-pro air pods and then here is
where it got
very exciting the most accurate apple
leaker of all time
kong or king i don't know with a 97.8
percent accuracy rating
said that the new air pods are ready to
ship
and could launch basically anytime this
is so
bullish that it points to them literally
being released
next week at the apple event which is
extremely exciting but wait
don't get too excited because i have
something to admit
so far this entire video has been
the good news and now it's finally time
to get into
the bad news ming chi kuo just came out
with a new report
claiming that airpods 3 mass production
will begin
in quarter 3 of this year which
basically begins
in july yep he's saying that the airpods
3
will not be released at apple's march
events
basically going against everyone else so
yeah
there's definitely some bad news and
what basically makes it even worse
is that he initially thought that they
would launch between april and june
but now they won't even begin production
until july at the soonest
pointing to a launch in the fall but on
the plus side
qo believes that the airpods 3 will be
so good that they'll account
for 40 of the total airpod shipments
in 2021 even with them coming
later now here's what's really weird we
have quo on one side
saying that they won't begin production
until the third quarter of 2021
but at the same time you also have the
absolute most reliable leaker
kong saying that they're ready to ship
right now
so it's definitely a weird situation but
with that said
let me get into when i personally
believe that the airpods 3 are gonna
show up
due to his track record i'd personally
bet on kong being correct
but keep in mind that he didn't say that
they're arriving at the march event
he simply said that they're ready and
then
on top of that it's intriguing that kuo
totally went against kong even though
he's been
so reliable on top of that the fact that
52 audio has been showing
actual photos of the airpods 3 points to
them
actually being ready to go right now and
if you take a look at 52 audio's track
record
they leaked the actual airpods pro at
the beginning of october
in 2019 and then apple officially
released them less than a month later on
october
30th so based on that i believe that
there's a good chance we could
actually see the airpods 3 get released
at the event next week
or if not april is definitely a
possibility
since there was a report from mack
atacara claiming that the new airpods
pro
are coming in april alongside a new
iphone sc
so maybe the threes will come alongside
that as well but then again
what if the new airpods pro are
releasing soon and it's actually the
airpods 3
that end up coming later this year
matching up to what quo is saying
but i personally think that the regular
model is coming
first because in 2019 apple
actually released the airpods 2 in march
but they didn't announce them during the
march event
they actually released them six days
earlier
on march 20th through a regular press
release
so what if apple does the exact same
thing
this year releasing the airpods 3
before the event next week which means
that we could actually see them getting
released
on wednesday the 17th which would of
course be
the best case scenario and this would in
turn give them more time during the
event
to focus on other new products like the
ipad pro
the air tags the apple tv and apparently
maybe even the redesigned imac so we'll
just have to see
but with all that said i believe that
the airpods 3 are going to be a huge
deal
since it's been a while since we've got
new airpods
literally two full years since the
airpods 2.
because of that i believe that there are
a ton of people waiting to upgrade
even people who have the og airpods
like myself and even despite the lack of
new products
airpods sales are still up 22
year over year so i feel like these
airpods 3
will sell like hotcakes so there you
guys go hopefully you enjoy this video
and if you totally disagree with any of
my personal speculations
go ahead and comment your thoughts down
below definitely check out one of those
two videos right there
click the circle about to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]